as more and more people are choosing to
get vaccinated vaccination centers also
notice
more families are showing up families
saying it's better just do it all
together
i told you sally was busy earlier today
sally jeremiah
visited cashman center and sally you
spoke to families who decided to get
that dose together as one unit
brian many families say they are getting
the vaccine together because it's easier
convenient and together they can help
tackle covet 19.
i brought my mom and my brother a big
day for families who decided to get
their first dose of the coven 19 vaccine
while naranco was 17 years old he and
his family got pfizer felt like i needed
to do my part and get the vaccine
that uncle says his family recovered
from kova 19 and wants to make sure
they don't get it again it was quite
hard all of us were home
we had a place so people can bring this
food
and stuff we had we couldn't go out so
we were just home together
now together they have come to cashman
center she said let's all go so you guys
won't be afraid
when they are big i hope they also teach
their kids how to get their vaccines
i was quite happy because it's like
experience we always go together
so it was quite fun to be with my family
i came here you know so i could get
vaccinated
and so nothing could happen to me and my
family for the naranco family
they say it's always better when they're
together
i think because whenever it's family i
think like you know they won't get
scared that much you know they won't get
that much nervous because
they're with their family the leons who
also showed up
agree first for my health
and the health of my family it's very
important we believe this virus is very
complicated for the entire world
nervous but it's okay something good for
the things come back
to normal it was quite simple and i do
recommend it for
all families to come and get vaccinated
i've been told that at many locations
there is no wait i've also been told
wait times can be a little longer on
saturdays
for more information on the hours of
operation and the many locations you and
your family
can get the vaccine visit our website
eightnewsnow.com denise back to you